j'ai testé la nouvelle fonction du z 6 2
qui fait que à mon sens c'est le boîtier
clairement le plus sous côtés de 2021 et
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi dans
cette vidéo
[Musique]
oh
et salue les gens à l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mans
encore je suis ravie comme à chaque fois
de vous retrouver pour une nouvelle
vidéo et si vous êtes nouveau sur cette
chaîne ici on parle de comment faire des
vidéos comment les améliorer les
techniques le montage la captation
toussa toussa toussa donc si c'est
quelque chose qui vous intéresse vous
pouvez envisager de cliquer sur le petit
bouton sa monnaie qui se situe juste en
dessous on ne mange pas de pain c'est
gratuit on va donc parler de ce boîtier
qu'ils aident 6 2 qui a pas forcément
une réputation de ouf mais juste avant
je prends les précautions d'usagé en
disant que cette vidéo n'est pas
sponsorisé je ne suis pas payé pour dire
ce que je vais dire c'est uniquement est
purement mon avis alors il ya environ un
an je vous racontais dans une vidéo qui
s'affiche ici je sais jamais de quel
côté mon switch du sony alpha cède 3
vers le nikon et 6 2 explique un peu
pourquoi les détails du boîtier on ne va
pas forcément revenir sur ces raisons là
et les spex du boîtier ça vous pouvez
aller voir la vidéo qui est dédié n'a
aujourd'hui ce dont je voudrais parler
c'est surtout une fonctionnalité qui a
été rajouté après coup qui n'était pas
présente au moment où j'ai fait la vidéo
soit 6 de how long j'ai commencé et il
s'est passé pas mal de temps en fait
justement depuis cette vidéo c'est là
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de vidéos du
corporate du mariage du clip ya eu plein
plein de choses que j'ai fait avec et
mon avis à un petit peu évolué sur ce
boîtier c'est ce dont je veux vous
parler aujourd'hui
surtout que bon sans nommer personne il
ya quand même quelques influenceurs qui
m'ont un petit peu chambré 1 du fait que
je passais sur nikon à base de ouais
mais mon assiette est roi il fait si
ouais mais mon canot mersin qui fait ça
attendez vous n'êtes pas prêt parce
qu'il faut remettre les choses dans leur
contexte le set 6 2 c'est un boîtier qui
coûte environ 2000 euros donc c'est pas
non plus un des boîtiers les plus chers
du marché un sens est très très en
dessous du prix d'un ascète s3 ou d'un
canon r5 et avant même d'être une caméra
c'est déjà un appareil photo qui fait
des photos assez extraordinaire vous
encourage à aller faire un tour sur
instagram qui s'affiche ici juste pour
juger par vous même il ya aussi le fait
que les optiques nikon sont vraiment
très très bonne là pour le coup c'est
vraiment un truc me cogner un
savoir-faire d'opticiens qui est
vraiment incomparable donc très bon
boîtier photo pour un prix plutôt
abordable mais nous ce qui nous
intéresse ici c'est la vidéo est
effectivement la vidéo en interne c'est
pas ce qu'on pourrait appeler le gros
point fort du nikon z6 pendant un an
justement en 4k 60 fps mais cros paix en
cas de 0 8 bits on n'a pas de log en
interne donc on n'est quand même pas non
plus sur un truc de ouf mais encore une
fois c'est un boîtier à 2000 euros je
vous avais expliqué qu' on pouvait en
externe faire des choses beaucoup plus
sympa notamment au niveau du projet euro
qui est un codec raw créé par apple et
qui permet d'aller un peu plus loin
d'enregistrer de la vidéo eurovia un
enregistreur atomos et comment vous dire
je suis un petit peu quand même tombé
des nues je pensais prores roaa s'est
bien c'est trop cool et où est la nikon
annonce que tout simplement le z 6 2 va
être compatibles pour l'enregistrement
externe avec le bureau le black magic
heroes on peut donc enregistré du black
magic raw à l'aide d'un enregistreur
black magic qui coûte environ 800 balles
pas non plus un truc de fou et françois
il se disait ben proposeront au bureau
c'est pareil ça reste dur hausse et non
non non l'erreur erreur monumentale
le bureau s'est juste ouf on est quand
même beaucoup plus proche avec le bureau
du raid code des caméras red que avec le
projet euro par exemple le bureau ça va
nous permettre une latitude juste
incroyable alors le point qui pourrait
être un petit peu rédhibitoire pour
certains c'est que le bio on peut lire
qu'avec davinci résolve
donc c'est un petit peu contraignant
mais d'un autre côté pour l'étalonnage
davinci résolve c'est quand même un
petit peu le must donc ça serait dommage
de se priver d'utiliser ce logiciel la
juste parce que on veut pas utiliser le
bureau il ya notamment tout un tas de
choses qu'on ne peut faire avec le
bureau qu'on ne peut pas faire avec le
pro réseau et ça se situe au niveau des
espaces colorimétriques par exemple un
espace colorimétrique qui marche très
très bien et je vous renvoie à la vidéo
d'adelin et d'emmanuel pompe urique
avait parlé de ça c'est celui des
caméras alexa oui il est arrivé qu'on a
un signal euros on peut choisir l'espace
colorimétrique qu'on veut le gamin le
gamut et avec le projet zéro on est
quand même assez limité iliad us loeb je
crois il loeb de kanon le look de dj n'y
a pas beaucoup possibilités en termes de
changements de l'espace colorimétrique
là vraiment on peut faire ce qu'on veut
on peut tout comme sur les caméras red
changer les méthane est a posteriori les
iso la balance des blancs les correction
d'exposition bref on peut faire tout un
tas de choses après avoir shooté ça
c'est quand même assez cool et ça me
rappelle clairement marc est un vraiment
même en termes de qualité d'image je
vous laisse comparer je vous laisse
juger mais franchement le z 6 avec
l'enregistreur black magic
c'est pas si loin que ça de l'art est
dans la dure aux douze buts et passes 16
bits comme sur la règle mais c'est déjà
un très très très très intéressant et
surtout on n'a pas acheté une nouvelle
caméra et c'est ça qui est assez où je
vous montre le rig que j'ai utilisé donc
ici on à l'enregistreur black magic avec
deux batteries un ssd ici pour
enregistrer les fichier en externe il
n'y a pas besoin de deux caddies comme
pour l'atome au sein simple ssd type
samsung ça marche aussi j'ai ma cage
small rig mon petit câble hdmi et voilà
et en avant guingamp c'est parti quoi il
j'ai même tendance à préférer cet
enregistreur là plutôt que la tomate
parce que je trouve qu'il est plus
fidèle déjà en terme de rendu on a un
aperçu qui se rapproche plus du résultat
final il ya le fait qu'il ya aussi plein
geeti d'assistance à l'exposition à la
mise au point qu'ils sont vraiment très
très bien fichu et cet enregistrement
sur des disques externes ça c'est juste
super cool c'est vraiment vraiment
pratique ce qu'on sort le disque on le
branche alors dit est terminée je suis
donc partie tourné un clip avec mon pote
ben qui fait de la musique électro qui a
aussi fait la musique notamment de la
websérie qui avait sur la chaîne en me
disant maintien on va tester un petit
peu le matos on va voir ce fameux codex
ce qu'il donne je vous mets des images
d'illustration pour voir un petit peu à
quoi ça ressemblait mais si vous voulez
voir le clip en entier le lien est dans
la description je vous encourage
vivement allez le voir parce que c'est
une très bonne musique et que c'est un
très bon clip également voilà on va te
des fleurs françois audet l'enregistreur
j'avais donc - m6 et le 24 70 f 2,8 de
chez nikon un petit fils prennent des
freewares variable qui est pratique en
plus ce truc-là magnétique avec un
filtre mist aussi une des plus mm j'aime
beaucoup parce que ça donne c'est tout
sympa et c'est toujours pas sponsorisé
est clairement était sur le cul du
résultat on a tous été sur le cul du
résultat à tel point que des fois tu dis
est ce que ça vaut le coup de sortir la
red à noter quand même que le set 6-2 de
base ne peut pas gérer le bureau et le
pr réseau il faut un retour atelier chez
nikon qui coûte environ 200 euros ou
alors acheter directement le kit
filmmaker ou là le firent moins et déjà
mis à jour alors concrètement et là on
va répondre à cette question pourquoi je
pense que le v6 2 et le boîtier le plus
sous côtés de 2021 c'est qu'à la base on
a un boîtier qui est bon serre qui fait
de très bonne image en photo comme en
vidéo la vidéo en interne c'est pas le
truc le plus cool de la terre mais c'est
largement exploitable j'ai fait plein de
prod avec le codec interne et il ya eu
aucun souci personne ne s'est jamais
plaint et moi j'étais très content des
prod mais surtout avec l'arrivée de
cette compatibilité avec le black magic
ro on va mettre le set 6 2 totalement
sous stéroïdes et avoir une caméra qui
envoie un truc de fou car vous allez me
dire oui mais pourquoi pas acheter une
caméra blackmagic par exemple a bien
déjà parce que tu as une caméra blake
m'a dit que c'est pas un appareil photo
on garde la polyvalence sur le set 6-2
pouvoir faire de la photo de
l'enregistrement juste en interne parce
qu'on n'a pas besoin de forcément de
faire d'euros sur tous les projets et
aussi si on veut de faire du black magic
rossi vraiment on a un truc qui envoie
du lourd alors qu'une black magic
pockets et ben déjà c'est juste une
caméra c'est du micro 4/3 ou du super 35
donc pas du plein format on n'a pas le
look plein format non plus même si c'est
pas obligatoire on se retrouve donc avec
un z si ce qui est une pure bête de
course pour faire de la fiction du clip
on peut aussi avoir quelque chose de
très léger pour faire du corporate ou du
mariage bref c'est franchement plutôt
pas mal et même si nikon a commencé à
parler d'un z9 qui est devrait être
apparemment incroyable ils ont parlé de
huit cas et tout machin ça sera sûrement
pas dans les mêmes prix là pour deux
mille balles boîtier nu on est d'accord
on a quand même quelque chose qui est
très très très évolutif et qui permet de
faire énormément de choses d'une manière
très très très qualitative qui n'ont pas
forcément à voir toutes les
fonctionnalités qu'offre le z 6 c'est là
que je me dis françois tu as misé sur le
bon cheval quand même parce que je vous
avoue qu'il ya un an j'aurais pas penser
que ce boîtier pouvait être aussi
performant est aussi polyvalent et ça
merritt le traditionnel coup de blaster
sur le pouce en l'air qui se situe juste
en dessous de la vidéo ça mérite aussi
de vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà
fait et surtout d'aller voir une autre
vidéo qui s'affiche ici parce que j'ai
plein de choses intéressantes cette
chaîne paul est là ou là allez-y je vous
attends moi j'ai tout mon temps
ciao